i
[Música]
ah
en argentina según datos oficiales más
de 1 de cada 10 personas tienen algún
tipo de discapacidad el estado argentino
tiene una agencia nacional de
discapacidad una ley específica y
garantiza una serie de derechos para las
personas con discapacidad también con
diferencias regionales y ha ido
avanzando en acceso a la salud al empleo
y a la movilidad pero están lejos de
brindar todo lo necesario para que las
personas con discapacidad puedan vivir
con plenitud y altos niveles de
autonomía es un problema que se ha
profundizado durante la pandemia de kobe
19 según un relevamiento difundido a
mediados de este año por la organización
civil red por los derechos de las
personas con discapacidad durante la
pandemia a las personas con discapacidad
vieron afectados entre otras cosas su
vida independiente en la comunidad y el
acceso a la salud y un informe de la
agencia nacional de discapacidad da
cuenta de que en los primeros seis meses
de la pandemia la letalidad por kobe 19
en la población con discapacidad fue
casi 5 puntos porcentuales más alta que
en la población general
[Música]
una ciudad española castellón de la
plana ha sido galardonada como segunda
ciudad europea más accesible en este
2020 un reconocimiento que otorga la
comisión europea precisamente para
reconocer los trabajos de los
ayuntamientos a la hora de levantar
barreras tanto urbanísticas como
cognitivas y hacer así las ciudades
accesibles a todas las personas sin
embargo este positivo ejemplo no debe
eclipsar la larga lucha que queda
todavía por hacer aquí en españa contra
la discriminación de las personas con
alguna discapacidad sin embargo uno de
los ejemplos más conocidos en este país
de la normalización de la discapacidad
es el ejemplo del doctor en física y
también diputado pablo echenique que con
una importante discapacidad física es
uno de los diputados con más peso dentro
de las filas de unidas podemos sin
embargo no puede sentarse en la bancada
junto a sus compañeros de partido porque
el hemiciclo no está adaptado además ha
recibido alguna burla por parte de otro
diputado del partido popular
[Música]
efe se llevó una mención especial en los
accésit y words que recompensan los
esfuerzos en materia de accesibilidad de
las ciudades europeas la ganadora de
este año fue en varsovia pero el jurado
quiso resaltar lo logrado por el foro de
una pequeña ciudad a unos 100 kilómetros
al noroeste de parís allí se lleva a
cabo la sonorización de las semáforos
para las personas invidentes y también
se puso a disposición en lectura fácil
toda la documentación municipal francia
cuenta con cerca de 12 millones de
personas en la situación de discapacidad
y una ley de 2005 permite protegerlas y
sobre todo integrarlas aún más a la
sociedad en materia de educación pero
también de empleo en cuanto a
accesibilidad las ciudades francesas aún
no han puesto al día la totalidad de sus
infraestructuras y de hecho según el
sondeo más reciente todavía hay andenes
a muy altos faltan rampas y en general
la vía pública está llena de obstáculos
lo cual no facilitan los desplazamientos
[Música]